[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation qu'elle soit demandée par
les descendants autoproclamé de victimes
ou dans la bouche de ceux qui veulent
reconstruire l'histoire pour ne pas
l'assumer
la repentance est un sentiment nouveau
une position nouvelle aux conséquences
extrêmement graves pour l'avenir
condamner des périodes du passé en
ignorant l'état d'esprit de l'époque les
circonstances et les faits s'apparentent
à un magistrat qui jurait sans avoir lu
son dossier
l'intimé conviction ou la certitudes
arrogantes ne sont pas de mise pour les
élus de la république au service du
peuple qu'ils sont censés défendre et
non culpabiliser comme le disait et
lille et vit sur l'affairé halimi le
choix de la repentance remplace la
france éternelle celle de l'honneur et
du devoir
celle des lumières et du courage par la
france coupable celle de la honte et dui
les honneurs que les plus hautes
autorités de l'état se prêtent à ce jeu
mortifère est la preuve que nous sommes
dans une crise majeure qui nous pénalise
dans les instances internationales
ils paradoxe de ces repentance
répétitives c'est qu'en même temps on
accumule les commémorations de grands
personnages du passé comme si on voulait
bénéficier des retombées de leur image
pour se donner une stature mise à mal
par nos contrition successives
il est vrai que ceci s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la promotion dogmatique d'une
conception du futur imposant une vision
de l'avenir qui élimine l'état nation
s'intégrant dans l'europe celle du
général de gaulle du président pompidou
dans l'esprit ces deux dirigeants
amoureux de leur pays il fallait
défendre les intérêts de leurs citoyens
fédérer dans une identité nationale
autour de valeurs républicaines d'une
culture et d'un patrimoine issu de leur
histoire et non de la couleur de peau
l'évolution a commencé il y a quelques
années quand contrairement à la plupart
des pays d'europe
nous avons refusé d'inscrire nos racines
chrétiennes dans la constitution
par suite d'un dévoiement du concept de
laïcité
l'objectif actuel est de promouvoir
l'état sans frontières où le citoyen n'a
plus une influence sur les décisions
face à une oligarchie dominante
européiste ou mondialistes dans la ligne
du forum de davos et du milliardaire
george soros
il s'agit de déconstruire la france pour
la dissoudre dans une entité
supranationale qui semble porteuse
d'avenir pour réussir ce passage à cette
dimension européenne
les français devront oublier leur
histoire et abandonner leur droit
d'existence pour être des citoyens ayant
perdu leurs références se mélangeant
avec des populations venues d'ailleurs
dans un espace juridique sans frontières
cette pratique de la contrition devenu
élément de politique extérieure s'est
trouvé légitime et par l'exigence de
repentance
en politique intérieure face aux
minorités toutes origines comme le
signalait le ministre clément bonne dans
une interview récente
elles sont soutenues par une gauche qui
a abandonné le peuple social dans une
dérive vers l'extrême gauche
communautariste mise en avant par
certains médias est devenue dès août
idéologique
propagande elle rejette des pans entiers
de ce qui a fait la france en utilisant
la décolonisation comme théologie de la
libération
en joignant selon la méthode définie par
vladimir volkoff l'approximation
involontaire à la tromperie délibérée
il s'agit de déconstruire notre propre
histoire pour satisfaire ces minorités
racialiste indigéniste islamo gauchiste
et bien sûr antisémite pour qui la
repentance n'est qu'une étape
pratiquant d'autres règles il s'appuie
sur une idéologie qui refusent les
principes fondamentaux de liberté et
d'égalité et volent créer des
territoires à leur image dans un
processus de colonisation de peuplement
et de conquête des esprits
considérant que les fautes du
colonisateur sont inexpiable comme
l'expliquent christian de molinier dans
la croisade du mal pensants ces
minorités se victimise pour interdire à
la majorité s'exprimer dans le but de
les priver de leurs droits
et c'est d'autant plus facile comme le
précise lætitia strauss bonnart dans le
point du 8 avril que notre société
en substituant comme système de valeurs
la sécurité matérielle émotionnel à
l'honneur et à la dignité donne la
priorité à la victime dans une
reconnaissance devenu complaisance qui
relativise l'effet loin de la recherche
permanente de la mesure prônée par
aristote
nous sommes confrontés à l'émergence
année au fascisme de la diversité
constitué de mouvements totalitaires et
anti-démocratique leurs pratiques
outrancière de rejet et d'exclusion
en fonction de la couleur de peau des
idées ou des origines en sont une
démonstration permanente
d'humiliation en humiliation face aux
groupes de pression minoritaires et aux
états qui les soutiennent les français
finissent par se sentir coupables sans
même essayer de se défendre
nous sommes devenus les boucs émissaires
de tous les maux nous nous en excusons
et chaque acte de repentance est perçu
dans tous les pays émergents et les pays
non démocratiques comme une
démonstration de faiblesse qui justifie
d'en demander un autre comme l'écrivait
albert camus il est bon qu'une nation
soit assez forte de tradition pour
trouver le courage de dénoncer ses
propres erreurs mais elle ne doit pas
oublier les raisons qu'elle peut avoir
de s'estimer elle même il est dangereux
en tout cas de s'avouer seul coupable et
de se vouer à une pénitence perpétuelle
on en a pour preuve le rapport stora sur
l'algérie que dénonce serge barcellini
président du souvenir français car il
passe sous silence les morts pour la
france qu'ils soient civils ou
militaires
il fait suite à la condamnation de la
colonisation française
considéré comme un crime contre
l'humanité dans une négation de
l'histoire des c 130 ans puis à
l'hommage qui fut rendu à des membres du
fln choquant profondément ceux qui
vécurent sert période on peut considérer
que ces actifs sûrs commis dans
l'intention louable de faire avancer
dans la voie de la vérité de la justice
mais il aurait dû pour le moins avoir
une réciprocité de la part du
gouvernement algérien
loin de s'en satisfaire celui ci n'a pas
hésité à tordre la vérité historique
dans la ligne de son ministre du travail
qui nous a catalogué le 8 avril comme
l'ennemi traditionnel et éternelle
certes la colonisation d'un pays par un
autre
réduit ce dernier a les dates population
sujette avec inévitablement des abus et
des crimes
c'est l'histoire de tous les temps et de
tous les hommes
il n'est donc pas question d'oublier les
faits les répressions féroces
en réponse à des attentats sanglants et
un statut indigènes très regrettable
mais ce que nous condamnons aujourd'hui
n'étaient au cours de toute l'histoire
du monde que pratique courante pour les
populations du nord vers le sud d'est en
ouest et vice versa il illégitime de
reconnaître que l'algérie a connu sous
la colonisation un développement
économique et social incontestable alors
qu'en des temps plus lointain elle a été
dévastée par l'empiré ottoman en
répliquant pas à ce déni de l'histoire
nous donnons raison aux gouvernements
successifs algérien qui refuse de
reconnaître leur échec dans le
développement de leur pays
après sa libération pour l'expliquer ils
en rendent responsable colonisateur en
oubliant de se comparer à tous les pays
décolonisés à la même époque et qui eux
ont réussi
ceux-ci qui fait qu'en france pour une
petite partie agissante et agressive de
la population d'origine immigrée et même
s'il profite des avantages sociaux
qu'ils n'auraient pas dans leur propre
pays d'origine
nous sommes des coupables éternelle de
surplus sur le sol algérien
des opposants au régime en place
manifestent chaque semaine on nous
assimile ans à leurs dirigeants actuels
cette volonté de victimisation fait
monter la n2 se diraient même de tous
ceux qui se sentent exclus
d'autant qu'ils sont souvent encouragés
par des imams finances et de l'extérieur
qui les pousse à ne pas s'intégrer et à
rejeter toute assimilation
cette pratique obsessionnelle de la
repentance se pratique au nom de la
transparence que jean denis bredin
définit comme la terrible et unique
vertu d'une époque qui a oublié toutes
les autres elle s'impose dans l'esprit
de nos dirigeants comme la condition
incontournable d'une gouvernance
responsable moderne
pourtant ils devraient savoir que dans
l'histoire du monde chaque fois qu'un
état la pratiquer il a basculé peu après
dans la dictature et ceci explique
pourquoi cette exigence est si chère au
coeur des idéologues extrémistes rêvant
de réformer le monde à leur image
problème gênant tient au fait que ceux
qui la prônent ne l'appliquent pas quand
il s'agit de leurs intérêts ou quand ils
arrivent au pouvoir regarder avec quel
soin la plupart de nos partis politiques
refusent de publier la totalité des noms
de leurs généraux donateurs nous
trouvons un autre exemple des limites de
cette transparence dans l'utilisation de
la raison d'état pour cacher la vérité
le président du tchad le maréchal idriss
déby a été tué non pas au combat mais
lors d'une réunion avec son état major
le matin des élections bien avant la
proclamation des résultats
constatant d'assassinât et sachant que
la majorité de la population souhaitait
un changement après cinq mandats de
dictature et de chasse systématique aux
opposants incluant sa propre famille
des élections auraient dû se faire
immédiatement les français pour
préserver l'implication indispensable de
l'armée tchadienne dans l'opération
barkan on préférait entériné la mise en
place pour 18 mois d'un comité militaire
dirigée par le fils du président deby
dans la logique actuelle de transparence
et d'europe intense
le minimum aurait été de s'en excuser
auprès des tchadiens
nous en sommes moins qu'on a pu le voir
à l'enterrement de celui qui nonobstant
aura été un grand soldat avec un courage
réellement exceptionnel quand mer rouge
cambodgiens ont envahi phnom penh tous
les journaux de la gauche française ont
applaudi l'arrivée des libérateurs
des années plus tard quand le génocide a
été connue seul jean daniel du nouvel
observateur a eu le courage de la vraie
repentance en s'excusant sa prise de
position antérieures il ya peu face aux
problèmes de vaccinations contre la
copie 19
on a entendu la chancelière allemande
s'excuser cet aveu de ses propres fautes
est extrêmement rare car il est plus
facile de se repentir sur les fautes
présumées des autres que d'assumer
courageusement les siennes mais ne
rêvons pas on n'a pas vu le président
bush présenté ses excuses pour brandt un
hameau et l'usal institutionnel de la
torture dans les prisons de la cia à un
niveau rarement égalé jusqu'ici
n'attendez pas que le président biden
sénateur du puy 30 ans du plus grand
paradis fiscal mondial de la war
s'excuse d'avoir contribué à faire
interdire tous les paradis fiscaux
européens comme le disait un cardinal
anciens primats de belgique quand la
prudence est partout le courage est
nulle part
en réalité sous la pression médiatique
et la raison d'état on pratique une
sélection du bien et du mal à géométrie
variable
on ne se repent pas sur nos relations
avec les dictateurs africains qui
s'affranchissent de leurs constitutions
ailleurs par contre on s'érige en juge
pour rendre la justice de manière
partisane en oubliant la morale et les
règles de droit al qaïda devient
sympathique et on lui fournit de
l'armement
quand il s'attaque à la syrie mais il
devient criminel si les attaques à la
france jamal al nostra est un groupe de
combattants rebelles à idlib en syrie
mais devient un mercenaire turc en libye
on s'intéresse au sort des ouigours mais
on oublie les centaines de milliers de
morts d'irak et d'afghanistan où le
nombre de civils tués a été cent fois
plus important que celui des militaires
on s'inquiète sur les premiers jours de
la grève de la faim de navalni il a
d'ailleurs arrêté depuis
on ne dit rien sur la mort aux deux cent
trente huitième jour de grève de la faim
de l'avocat turc et brutin tic qui
demandait simplement qu'on lui fasse un
procès équitable
on expulse des diplomates par mesure de
rétorsion pour l'empoisonnement de
sergueï skripal
et on ferme les yeux pour l'assassinât
de jamal khashoggi on justifie des
guerres économiques et politiques au nom
des droits de l'homme ou dans sa version
humanitaire du droit d'ingérence dans
les balkans ou en libye en définitive
nous sommes dans la ligne
vahé victis le malheur au vaincu de
lempire de rome tout ce que pensent et
font les dirigeants occidentaux
d'aujourd'hui bien et moral tandis que
ce qu'ont pu faire leurs prédécesseurs
mais aujourd'hui leurs adversaires et
forcément immoral à ce stade
comme l'écrit dans son dernier livre la
philosophe monique canto sperber
ancienne présidente de normale sup
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le bien
comme on ne peut réfuter
on préfère et on empêche d'en parler la
prétention morale excusant la sangsue
ainsi l'interdiction de l'autre est
devenue la norme et la tolérance
une concession alors qu'elle était une
vertu
eugénie bassier dans la guerre des idées
précises que la caractéristique du débat
actuel n'est pas le culte du clash et de
la polémique
mais le refus de la confrontation au nom
du droit à ne pas être offensé qui est
totalement subjectif on interdit les
changes et les coûts d'une opinion
différente
confondant les deux on refuse le vrai au
nom de ce que l'on croît être le bien
dans un texte lumineux de 1989
régis debray a défini les différences
entre la république et la démocratie
il a montré combien les partisans de
cette dernière
inspiré par les états unis et l'europe
du nord acceptent par exemple des signes
religieux au nom du droit des individus
et de l'évolution de la société vers le
multiculturalisme de l'autre côté les
républicains souhaitent un régime dans
lequel la nation et l'intérêt général
peut sans les nier ou les abolir
transcender les divisions de la société
pour instituer un véritable espace
public
ainsi la démocratie communautarisme et
la république assimile la synthèse
consiste à faire aimer la france sa
langue et son histoire à tous ses
enfants
malheureusement c'est un discours
nostalgique et patriotique qui est
largement rejetée par une partie de
l'éducation nationale qui préfèrent
gracchus babeuf un napoléon et
l'écriture inclusive à la dictée de
mérimée le professeur jean-françois
chemin dans son plaidoyer pour une
république plus française ajoute qu'il
ne suffit pas de s'autoproclamer le pays
de la liberté des droits de l'homme
encore faut-il que cela s'inscrive dans
les actes or depuis qu'elle a permis aux
nazis d'accéder au pouvoir en allemagne
en 1933
la démocratie est considéré avec
méfiance par une grande partie de
l'oligarchie qui veut maintenir la vente
et populaire sous le couvercle d'acier
des bons sentiments de l'élite
le refus obstiné de la pratique du
référendum est une démonstration
évidente de cette peur de la vraie
démocratie directe mais la bienveillance
souvent laxiste de nos élites envers
l'agressivité des minorités tous ordres
et de moins en moins comprise et suscite
des réactions
toutes parts quand la justice et des
ministres se mettent au dessus des lois
pour privilégier l'émotion tout devient
possible
à vouloir étouffer les révolutions
pacifiques on rend inévitable les
révolutions violentes a dit john kennedy
sous les coups de boutoir des partisans
sectaire de la diversité finkielkraut
voit dans la désintégration française un
camp du refus et un camp de la
soumission dans ce type de situation
l'homme d'état doit oublier la pratique
du verbe pour gouverner et agir avec
courage
il doit reconstruire l'unité dans une
communauté de destin en fixant des
objectifs partagés pour créer
l'espérance en un avenir commun il doit
redonner aux français cette confiance en
eux vantées par tocqueville
on ne peut abandonner la majorité de sa
population sur le bord de la route ou
pire la sacrifier sous prétexte qu'ils
sont des boumeurs issu d'une histoire
que l'on renie plutôt que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier pour
répondre aux amis de madame traoré
pourquoi ne pas mettre au panthéon
les cendres de gaston monnerville avocat
noir d'origine guyanaise petit fils
d'esclave et résistants qui fut maire de
saint-céré et conseiller général pendant
25 ans du département du lot au coeur de
la france profonde et deuxième
personnage de l'état comme président du
sénat de 1958 à 1968 il tenait tête à de
gaulle et c'était pas facile et
défendent est passionnément la
république
mais comme dit la chanson
cela fait partie d'une histoire que les
moines 40 ans ne veulent pas connaître à
bientôt
[Musique]